the best aspect of being a camera
operator has got to be the sort of
physical one to one with the camera and
creating a shot that the directress has
in his mind's eye let's say and you have
to decipher his the nuances of what he
wants from what he's brought bill read
from the script and make that practical
well you're always helping the drive to
achieve their vision a lot of it is just
listening listening to your directors
watching your actors you've often given
a task so you've set your camera whether
it be a track and you know you've got
various actors coming at various times
larger is just letting it all play out
so when something's rehearsed you get to
get a feel for how it's all going and
which is the best place to put yourself
in order to tell that story i joyed the
buzz of being on set I like the
creativity working with different
directors different directs photography
some people like to dictate where you
put the camera and other people will
give you more of a free rein and ask you
to sort of put your creativity into it
it is completely different from working
on a single drama where you're working
with the same dop and director for maybe
three or four months it makes it
certainly more interesting in a way
because everybody's got a different
approach to how they were and you just
adapt to that really the creativity is
always there but often you do work to
instruction and then try and build on
that idea so even though the idea might
be given to you so your duty still to
keep improving on that idea and keep it
going when I frame a shot you watched
the scene you read the words you try and
appreciate the location you're in which
it can be often either geographical or
light-driven and then you start from the
beginning you start from usually from a
shot encompasses the whole scene and
then you break it down into sections
that will cover the people involved or
the story involved in that scene I look
for strong shots good nice compositions
but it's no good having a nice
composition if you're not telling the
story the story is the key thing isn't
it you know Lester says the sad
character or an angry character you will
immediately start finding a frame would
just be heavier or harder or lowering
the mood of the actor will also just
draw you to frame the camera in a
slightly different way so sometimes it's
not just that signature style that you
might have it's what's happening in
front of you which just draws your eye
to land the frame in a certain way I
think it's very much an instinct thing
be at a long shot or midshire or closer
it's just a question of getting the
right balance there's no hard and fast
rules to it really if a shot is wrong
it's more obvious than ever shot is
right you know it just doesn't see it
however there are no rules and sometimes
if you search around it it becomes very
interesting I would say the greatest
challenge we've come across some games
friends is probably the terrain for us
yes we shoot some very beautiful
photographs or at least I hope we do but
to get the cameras into those positions
and to overcome the challenges and still
make it look fantastic and great that's
the big thing wind rain heat often these
locations are dusty and gritty so the
gears always having to be sort of
carefully looked after the chances are
we'll have a lot of horses or a fight
sequence so we're going to generate more
dust as well as that will probably lots
of fire aspects in the probably lots of
special-effects guys with big fans
strain grip through them to even make it
even worse or whatever the environment
is we tend to sort of enhance it to make
it more exciting visually but as a
result yet it's quite punishing on the
cruise it's tough it's working a lot of
the time in rain and mud with the camera
covered up in plastic and us on gore-tex
out in all weathers and little things
like changing a filter becomes a major
deal I have to say that all the camera
systems and the grips do a fantastic job
and they make my job much easier it's
really the understanding that what you
see on the monitors or what you see
through the eyepiece of the cameras that
really is the work of absolutely every
on the crew for me is most important in
that that's recognizing that people
really sore
shape that it takes absolutely every
member of this crew for that to happen
and it be as good as it is over the six
seasons my experience on the entrance
has been quite extraordinary it's given
me such an exciting amount of challenges
crane work steadicam handheld it's just
been extraordinary I've been so very
very lucky and I will look back on it in
the s come within a great pride the
camera operates so much have the best
seat in the house you know you are right
at the front everything that happens
that camera is moved by you and you are
then with your actors and often if their
performances extraordinary which isn't
quite regular on the show then you
really are drawn in and really in a
fantastic place to be part of that best
seat in the house it really is
hey youtubers is charlie surprise
surprise there's new Game of Thrones
season 6 footage they wind up showing
off a couple big scenes so this is going
to be a breakdown switch is careful for
spoilers for potential season 6 stuff
some of this is going to be speculation
some of it's pretty obvious if you guys
didn't see my last game of Thrones video
too there's a new round of the giveaway
that's going on now for the season five
DVD all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just be doing that as my
weekly giveaway for the next couple of
weeks first big image Jack and hug are
in the house of black and white cleaning
another body they use the house of black
and white for that big teaser they have
all these posters now one that was for
WTF effect just to say anybody on the
show could die all men must die the
second reason they probably use that as
a teaser is because the many-faced God
and the teachings the faceless men are
probably going to continue to be a very
big thing throughout the season so as
Arya learns to live without her sight
and learns more about the culture of the
Faceless Men will just get to see more
and more from the temple of black and
white I can't wait is one of the most
interesting new places on the show
moving back to Westeros we're way up in
the north here you can see the snow on
the ground there's a large army in the
background and some of them have stark
leather on it looks like Ned Stark's
armor so they could be Karstarks they
could be stark loyalists I'm hoping just
in terms of scale the Second Battle of
Winterfell during season six reminds us
a lot of hardhome during season five
just big WTF battle crazy action gets
nominated for a bunch of awards because
it melts everyone's brains moving along
we see flayed men soldiers you can see
that the banner flowing up in the wind
up here probably from that same battle
next we have a couple Winterfell scenes
that they're filming the two young boys
here might be from a Winterfell
flashback from this three-eyed Raven
flash back here where Brandon the
three-eyed Raven are just looking at
something this could be a young Ned
Stark sparring with his older brother
Brandon if you look in the background to
you can see they're flying the stark
banner so this is not happening in
present day because in present day the
Bolton's hold Winterfell and the flayed
man banners are hung everywhere Brandon
Stark is someone that we've heard about
but we haven't seen yet he was killed by
the Mad King along with their father
Rickard stark in one of the events that
led to the beginning of Robert's
rebellion the story behind that's pretty
cool the Mad King had Brandon tied up so
that he couldn't reach his weapon and
was roasting his father Rickard stark
over a fire so Ned's father rickard died
from being burned
alive Brandon died because he choked
himself trying to reach his sword to
save his father from being burned alive
so big WTF don't know if we're ever
gonna see it on the TV show back to
marine we see Dario and surg oral
running through the streets there are a
couple other scenes with harpies so it
looks like the harpies are just going to
continue to be a big problem for them
don't know if the show is going to do
bloody flux but that's one of the other
big problems they face in the books it's
a really disgusting disease so the show
my just sidestep that and use the
harpies as internal marine problems to
be solved there are external problems
for marine too here's a bunch of
Dothraki sitting around Denarius walking
around their encampment sergej me on the
ship on his way back to King's Landing
with merciless body this almost looks
like me reread north of the wall but not
quite I can't quite tell the resolution
is just a little too blurry so you can
decide whether or not you think this is
Mira on her own but presumably if brain
is going to be training with the
three-eyed Raven and her primary duties
will be foraging for food unless brand
has some other tasks that he needs help
with going south to the wall this looks
like Melisandre staring into the flames
I'm really hoping we get a Melisandre
vision she's one of the few characters
that has visions in the books but we
haven't seen that on the show yet the
show's just skipped over those there's a
shot at Tyrion walking through frame so
the big takeaway is that there's going
to continue to be a bunch of battles in
murine they're probably going to be
filming it in different ways so even
though we've been to marine before we'll
see parts of it that we haven't seen
before big battle in the north
flashbacks in some stuff happening
beyond the wall they didn't include
anything from the white Walker unit the
unit that films the white Walker stuff
from last year they were filming stuff
for the end of season 6 so there's going
to be some kind of white Walker stuff we
just don't know what it's going to look
like yet there are largely two big film
units that film all the game of thrones
scenes there's the dragon unit in the
wolf unit but there's also a white
Walker unit just for filming white
Walker stuff hard home last year was a
good example of an episode where they
need a lot of extra work because it was
so big normally the scenes beyond the
wall that they filmed in the past were
relatively small only involved a couple
people it as the army of White Walkers
move south towards the wall the stuff
that they do around the wall will get
bigger and bigger and bigger so let me
know in the comments what's your
favorite part of this and do you really
like bonus features like this or do you
just like traditional trailers they're
probably going to drop the first big
trailer when the DVD drops in about two
weeks so what they might do before then
it just post more stuff like this which
actually reminds me giveaway time
congratulations to yesterday's giveaway
winner Jake rubashka you win a copy of
the season five DVD or blu-ray just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so and get your
contact details just in case you guys
haven't seen it george RR martin was
teasing a big twist that the books are
going to do that we won't get to see on
the show you can click here for my video
from that and you can click here for all
my other game of thrones teaser videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you